okay so I gave you a bit of a head start
and I literally just differentiate it on
the spot so this is my first derivative
with respect to time here's my second
derivative now this line right here I
have the second derivative but it's
still in terms of time do you notice
that let me just highlight that for you
there it is there's the T so this is
still as a function of time but I can
restate this in terms of the
displacement by noticing that what I
have here inside my square brackets I've
just put it in square brackets for the
specific purpose of sort of highlighting
it is it's not quite X is it it's not
quite X it's actually X Y a minus B once
you subtract that from both sides that's
what you have right so I've got this X
minus B now I wonder if this rings a
bell again talking back to exponential
growth and decay do you remember the
exponential growth in care didn't always
look like that if you weren't going down
to zero right or starting from zero we
talked about modified growth in decay
you got an ever so slightly different
differential equations remember that
things like say what was um Newton's law
of cooling was a really you know
important example that we looked at we
could say that you know the change in
temperature with respect to time was
going to be proportional to that the
temperature rather and it's different
from the environment right so that's a
really badly placed - Sun okay so you've
got that's a little better you've got
this same kind of relationship here it's
like yeah this is a little bit more
complicated but it's basically the same
kind of idea okay so what we have now is
here and you might want to put like sort
of big colors over this here are our
time equations our time equations so if
we know what time it is and how the
thing is moving according to its time
these are the equations we would use and
we would come up with the derivatives
and the second derivatives that go with
that in terms of time okay but these
guys over on the right-hand side like
this one here and this one here these
are not time equations they are
displacement equations displacement
equations plural
there's not just the displacement
equation but there are equations in
terms of the displacement and this is
for the second derivative in the context
of simple harmonic motion now once you
think about this it actually unlocks a
whole different way of like it's a whole
different perspective on the same kind
of situation why would it matter that we
think about things in terms of where you
are rather than thinking about them in
terms of when you are hmm so as an
example ah did I bring it with me ah I
didn't but this will this will do when
we think about simple harmonic motion
like we've already given you a few
examples when you have a look at the
questions one that I talked about was a
tired a boat moving up and down on a
tired it's doing this kind of thing
right but many of the instances of
simple harmonic motion don't have to do
with time they just have to do with
position right so for example if I've
got um let's just imagine my let's let's
call my left hand one that's just stable
it's not going anywhere and then I've
got my right hand which is moving around
on your left and it can move in
different spots with relation to this
elastic band okay
now think about what's going to happen
the further my right hand moves because
my left hand is just going to stay put
okay but further my right hand moves
what like you can you you're not feeling
this but you can see it can't you
what is the elastic band doing to my
right hand it's pulling it back towards
the center right just here and the
further I pull the further I pause
nothing to do with time right like I can
stop or I could take ages to go there or
I can do it really fast doesn't have
anything to a time it has everything to
do with where I am the further I pull
the more of an acceleration a change in
my motion is being put we call this a
force right so the further I pull the
more I'm going in the opposite direction
and if I go like say here right now my
right hand and my left hand on the same
spot what kind of foursomes is my right
hand experiencing right now it's not
experiencing any force is this stretch
you can see it's just staying there
loosely right so in this case with the
displacement of zero what acceleration
is happening zero so in fact if you did
this right the girls in the room who
have hair tides can actually do this
take those off and demonstrate it right
you're getting actually if you have a
knob
object moving under an elastic sort of
situation it exhibits simple harmonic
motion if it's trying to move back and
forth right right at the origin as it
were my left hand that wasn't moving
there's no force being exerted on it but
once you get to an extremity of motion
something is pushing you back okay so we
actually have a name for this again you
know you need to know the name but it's
kind of handy to have labels to talk
about things
both of these here's my other one both
of these are what we call a restoring
force a restoring force the further you
go in one direction it sends you back in
the other okay
the extension to students they actually
have to look at stuff like air
resistance or motion through a medium
that's the opposite of a restoring force
that's what we call a resisting force
it's like stopping you from going in
whatever direction you're trying to go
this is making the motion go on and on
and on okay now yeah question so when we
say force that's I'm a bit being a bit
sneaky here we don't really need to
worry about forces but forces are things
which change the kind of motion you're
doing that's another word for
acceleration in our context right which
is why when we when we go back to like
your 10 physics right we write this
right force is really it's it's what
happens when you think about
acceleration in proportionate how heavy
your object is okay but I don't want to
get too deep into that because it gets a
bit confusing in we don't have to worry
about what the nuances is so what we're
going to do is now that we can realize
that we can think about things not just
in terms of when you are but where you
are we're just going to take a brief
excursion
excuse me away from simple harmonic
motion to all the different kinds of
motion you can think about where things
are in terms of the displacement so I'm
gonna give you two examples of this
really quickly let's see if my project
doesn't go on to sleep yet hmm oh it has
gone to sleep oh there it is oh it's
because I can't see it yep sure so
think about this for a second right how
does gravity work what kind of force is
gravity exerting on an object well it
doesn't really depend on the time that
you're at it depends on where you are
right the closer you are to set object
right the more gravity it gets to exert
on you if you're really really far away
it doesn't really have an impact on you
right so this is a perfect example of
where you want to think about velocity
and acceleration in terms of where in
terms of displacement rather than in
terms of when does that make sense okay
let me give you one other one which is
really interesting which is someone else
including me into doesn't to recognize
these pictures a pretty old man I don't
know who remembers or how many people
watch The Fast and Furious movies
that's the fuse yeah okay so I watched a
few of them not all of them there's just
too many I can't keep up with all of
them but of course most of you who watch
the Fast and Furious movies know that of
course
Riley middle of I was are between I want
to say between seven and eight I can't
remember always when very tragically
Paul Walker like the one of main stars
of it passed away in in a tragic
accident right now
in order to understand what happened
they had to look at all of this okay now
what is this well this is just a picture
of of what happened after the fact right
but because what you've got are all
these marks on the road you know you can
work out and this is exactly what they
did right you can work out what the
motion was doing not in terms of time
times over we don't have like footage of
what actually happened but we can read
it in terms of where right we can say Oh
at this particular corner of the road
this is what his car must have been
doing and that's why it had a skid mark
right does that make sense so sometimes
situations can only be understood
through the lens of displacement rather
than through time okay does that make
sense